the lawyers file in for what was to be
the first day of trial the selection of
The Twelve jurors and the alternates had
been completed and opening arguments
were about to begin
but then a delay while the public and a
massive media contingent waited
shortly before 4 pm Tuesday a settlement
was announced the two sets of lawyers
came out the Dominion team appeared
jubilant the truth matters
lies have consequences
over two years ago
a torrent of Lies swept dominion and
election officials across America
into an alternative Universe of
conspiracy theories
causing Grievous harm to Dominion
and the country
today's settlement
of
787 million five hundred thousand
dollars
represents vindication
and accountability fox has admitted to
telling lies about Dominion
that caused enormous damage to my
company our employees and the customers
that we serve
nothing can ever make up for that
there was no immediate comment from the
fox lawyers the company instead released
a statement saying we acknowledge the
Court's rulings finding certain claims
about Dominion to be false this
settlement reflects foxes continued
commitment to the highest journalistic
standards
fox has avoided what could have been an
embarrassing cross-examination of its
high-powered anchors who Dominion
claimed knowingly supported baseless
lies the chairman of fox Rupert Murdoch
who in private emails acknowledged that
his Network had aired in this reporting
was also spared the possibility of
having to admit this in the dark
but the company's problems are not over
another voting machines company
smartmatic is bringing a similar case
against Fox it is claiming 2.7 billion
dollars in Damages and a public
acknowledgment that the network
knowingly lied
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington